hey everyone Steve Weintraub here at the
cinema center at marble which is the
collider Studio I want to give them a
huge thank you uh for being an awesome
uh sponsor partner uh it's a great place
in Toronto just being honest you guys
are here you can see it yep you know
um so I'm here with everyone behind hell
of a summer which is World premiering
here at the Toronto International Film
Festival
um I really want to know do you think
it's because the three of you were
stalking the festival last year I
witnessed the three of you going around
to movies you know um you saw at least a
few uh do you think that's the re I'm
making a joke here
though yeah we kept pestering them to
let us in yeah yeah eventually we
followed the pro we followed Cameron
Bailey around and we said please please
please no we we uh went last year it was
so fun Billy's been coming to the
festival for years
um because he lives here and went to
film school here and uh
it was just the best time and then we
met you and you gave me your card I
still have in my wallet that led to
nothing yeah but I mean what's this
what's this what's this what's right now
right now you know what's funny nothing
I'm joking around yeah you're right
actually I'm stupid sometimes
the
the no you did say though that when it
was time to promote you would come in
yeah yes it is true
I'll give you some credit
true all right so listen No One let's be
I'll be serious for a second no one
watching this will have seen the movie
yet or maybe five people will have so I
hate asking you to do this but like how
have you been describing the film to
friends and family
I did a good one laugh the last time but
I don't know if I can I don't okay
um hell of a summer it's uh it's a
summer camp comedy slasher it's an
ensemble Coming of Age movie
um about uh camper or a counselor I
should say who's a little bit older than
everybody else
um named Jason and he's back and he kind
of can't let his uh his Camp Glory Days
go and then a mask killer starts picking
off the teenage counselors one by one
and everybody sort of freaks out and
tries to survive the night tries to
survive oh this is your guys obviously
first film was talk a little bit about
the Genesis of this because the other
thing is a lot of people really debate
sometimes like what is going to be my
first feature you know because like it
it sometimes can really matter you know
so how much did you debate is this going
to be the thing we do first I debated it
forever and I think had Finn and I not
have made this film together it would
have just been such a like the fact that
we got to make it together it made it
less of a debate for for me yeah and it
just became the question of as soon as
somebody was willing to there was that
voice in the back of my head going are
you ready should you do this and I
thought what are you doing like I do it
even if you're not ready go do it when
you get to make a movie and you're young
and you get to make a movie about people
that are your age and you get to work
with all these incredible people
um so I would say that working with Finn
and knowing that we're co-directing and
it's really
it feels like from the beginning it
wasn't just like one of our films is our
film it's a film kind of about our
friendship and then as we opened up the
you know film to all these other people
it just became so much more than just
something that belonged to us so it made
a lot easier yeah and also I mean
specifically too but look what Billy was
saying it about being the movie being
about younger people I mean it was you
know we're writing about friends and
people that we knew and so it felt
natural for us to be writing about
people our own age so for the two of you
uh what was it about the project besides
them offering you five dollars each to
be in the movie yeah that five dollars
is very enticing oh yeah
um at Thai Diner yeah
um it was well first I mean the simplest
first thing is just one of the best
scripts I've read and and so you read
something like that that's about
that uses that that has genre but but in
service of characters where it's like
the people are what's creating and
pushing the genre
um that's very exciting and uh and then
we met and and you just I I I I think
like
I think it's pretty quick to know when
something is gonna be deeply special and
and that the that the group of people
are going to be a unique like Ensemble
of of great artists and I and that
that's what this was to me so
um it was very it was very easy and um
to to decide because it was pretty
instantaneously the thing that I think
we all really wanted to do yeah
I think when I first read it I felt like
it struck a good balance of like the
horror and the genre and then also it
kind of I don't know if you guys would
describe it as a realm come yeah okay
totally it like some of the scenes felt
really quiet and sweet and like reminded
me of some of my favorite rom-coms
than that so I like that it Blended a
lot of different genres and feelings and
personalities and then I loved meeting
with them and yeah I feel like I knew
instantly even before reading the script
but then yeah it was amazing this genre
can um have some blood and guts and I
don't know um how much blood and guts is
in the movie so what do you would want
to tease for blood and guts well the I
will say it's sort of uh you know it's
closer to like a scream sort of uh type
violence rather than like a green room
you know type violence it's like there's
a there's a really that was a huge
conversation we both had I mean of like
okay when is Gore fun and and and you
know can be great for the audience and
when can it be like upsetting and and
also great for the audience in a
different way like in a sort of make you
feel uh very uncomfortable and Disturbed
and uh but because because of film kind
of as Abby was saying is like a
Young rom-com At Its core we we never
wanted to go too far that you couldn't
come back to the to see the light uh in
it so we had an incredible team of
people and we have some like incredibly
awesome practical Gore yeah
um but also it was always something we
always wanted to keep it fun
um for everyone so for example like a
Sean of the Dead
yeah I mean Charlotte that there's that
part where they get the points up Torn
and a half and we're not we don't go
that far but um yeah I mean you know
yeah yeah there's some gnarly there's
some gnarly like um
like tubes blood tubes and stuff like
that in the film so yeah yeah I'm very
much looking forward yeah um so I'm
curious did you guys as a group or
individually watch any films or ask the
cast to watch any films to sort of get
ready before you stepped on set to like
inhabit the tone that you were looking
for yeah we we
sent I'm pretty sure in the group chat a
few films for people to watch right but
I think anybody watched this yeah but I
think I think it was more of like a
re-watch type situation because I think
a lot of people had seen a lot of the
films yeah with I think what we kind of
tried to do was just
um
share the kind of films that Finn and I
referenced so much in the writing of it
and in the preparation for directing it
and kind of like specifically with
comedy just kind of what we were looking
for and we always wanted everything to
feel very real and character based and
um I mean we had such an incredible
group of actors so that wasn't really
going to be a concern for us but a lot
of the ones you reference like Shawn of
the Dead is one super bad is one
um talks a lot about like bottle rocket
and Rushmore and sort of the comedy of
early Wes Anderson films
um and then yeah I mean do you guys
we talked a lot about movies but I don't
know if there's anything specific that I
watched Freaks and Geeks but I don't
think yeah yeah you sent me a picture of
Linda Cardellini yeah but because of her
jacket but then I thought this would be
a good thing to re-watch and the movie
with Kristen Stewart Jesse Eisenberg oh
Adventureland yeah that was actually the
big one while we were there yeah totally
yeah
um
just kept sending me Charlie bit my
finger like yeah Fred watch reruns of
entourage on the Stars
um no Rushmore we want we when we
finished shooting
um then they were showing bottle rocket
again that new I think is there some
restoration and then we went and saw it
at the end and that that was amazing I
mean we watched a lot of movies
throughout
um but I think more like weird
documentary like even deferral would
watch like weird documentaries like
three in the morning
together also like that lived in a big
like this old Victorian Victorian like
it was like a hotel slash Mansion weird
house it's like there's like there's
kind of a communal room with a piano
downstairs and a TV and a couch never
lived in the same in that same manner or
whatever this Tiny Town everyone except
for us yeah we do not live in the night
we did not know we had we lived in a
little Lodge and I'm not joking we'd get
home and we'd like at like four in the
morning we'd be in bed and you just like
see like the like just the little
ceiling like keep going like that and
you'd hear like some Critters and then
Finn would just text me from his room we
were like like this thin wall between us
I was like yeah same same thing yeah the
rats yeah but these guys are having a
blast they're like playing piano and
then I think the family move in it was
like yeah there was one 12 actors in
there and then like one family came in
to go on vacation and then why he's like
I'll be the worst thing ever they're
like why every time they're trying to go
home is everyone just sitting around
running lines like playing music we
watched them Windy City Heat together
but but I don't I think more just for
the joys of watching it yeah they had a
very tough shooting Sky I mean they were
it's a very tough yeah I just have a
hard life you know
um it's very tough so I want to actually
ask you guys a little bit about the
filmmaking which is
um uh so I like talking about the
editing room because you really don't
know what you have till you step in
there and it's where it all comes
together so how did the film change in
the editing room in ways you didn't
expect we had a very kind of lengthy
editing experience
um just doing a bunch of different
alternate sort of cuts
um I think the main thing was finding
the the tone and then also the balance
between well this is the upside same
thing twice the tone of the comedy but
then also just the balance of the the
horror and when is too much and we did
some test screenings with friends and
family and thankfully there was a few
people who put up their hand at the end
were like
that's pretty gnarly when this happened
I kind of was like bummed for like 10
minutes afterwards and then I didn't
laugh so much at the parts afterwards
like okay great good good today all
right don't show like don't go too far
it kind of gave me like I don't know I
think no both of us were talking about
this where it's like we kind of felt
like we had a little chip on our
shoulder because there were scenes with
that were like too bloody and gnarly
that we had to tone back because again
you're trying to like
yeah you're trying to strike the balance
and it's like yeah once you go too dark
it's really it can be hard to like
make the audience you know you gotta
make the audience like laugh again
um and not be too Disturbed
um so that was a lot of I mean that was
a lot of it just a lot of test gradings
um
like how dumb is each character really
it was like because we had the actors
I mean this is not a dumb thing Fred we
could have cut your performance so
differently yeah because there's such a
range of takes every time and they were
all so interesting but it's like just
finding the through line there and when
is it too far
yeah he's like Jack Nicholson from The
Shining like we could have done a full
different cut where he's like not the
sort of yeah main character hero
Anchorman 1.5 but it's yeah yeah but
yeah I'm curious um I uh of course uh
I'm not trying to uh go into anything
strike related but um you you work on a
show that you have been around some very
gifted filmmakers and uh Sean Levy told
me yesterday that you were like a sponge
trying to see what duffers were doing or
what Sean is doing so what what did you
guys learn from your previous
experiences that you absolutely wanted
to take with you on as directors on set
well I think a lot like a lot of it is
just like do doing it like you learn it
on the go like you're learning it as
you're making it
um for me I mean I don't I mean I've
just learned a lot about like how to
talk to crew like and uh
you know making cast feel comfortable or
stuff like that I mean obviously very I
was still really learning when we did it
like truly like we were learning as we
went we've worked together a few times
with people who very different directors
were both so incredibly gracious with
both of us
um and we worked I mean yeah yeah I'll
just talk about people we worked with
Jesse Eisenberg and he was one of the
first people who read the script and he
was so supportive of it so so supportive
of it and just the way that he worked
with actors was so incredible and also
yeah communicated with crew and then
Jason Reitman also has been such a huge
supporter of us
um as
filmmakers and and like just I feel like
learned so much in the small amount of
time that I got to spend watching him
work but I really started
I I love acting and I wanted to act when
I was a kid I sort of started acting to
get on set and learn the craft of
filmmaking and I feel like any time I
was on set
um just just becoming more comfortable
and just seeing what it's sort of like
because it's an actor's perspective like
an actor's job can be you're very
sheltered and that's the point and then
to sort of be on the other side of that
and be like okay let's protect the
actors from the fact that it's gonna
rain in 30 minutes and we can't get this
scene and we're freaking out but like
don't let them know because it's their
job to not be worried about that I'm
surprised though I didn't freak the
actors out more of how many times I was
freaking I was just like oh get screwed
what's all screwed meanwhile the whole
every actor standing outside that can
hear me
um but no I mean yeah totally I mean
it's all just learning by watching
um so there's like specific you know
there's specific
choices that we make as directors that
can come from things that we've just
seen in the past from other directors I
guess I also felt that in you being but
let
and them being open about
all of the things that they knew so
deeply that like the taste that they had
what they knew needed to be the case but
also the things that they were learning
on the go by being open about that I
thought it created at least for me like
such an immense trust there because you
because you know that you know you're
ever in that you're making this with is
not hiding anything from you in regard
and it's what allows for I think us than
all different actions to give
performances that that in a thing that
is so many different tones put together
hits each of those
um but that so I think like in a way too
you never like um you never puffed your
chest so hard that either that so I made
it it just made it really really
wonderful to be directed by because
because you knew all the things that
they knew very well and you also knew
the things that you were learning in
real time which made it even more
exciting I would say I'm curious uh I'm
gonna ask them another question is
directors did you find that each of you
are more in like inclined like one of
you is more uh interested in where the
camera is and one is more interested in
crafting performance or was it one of
these things where you're a two-headed
Beast doing the same thing I would say
it was just constantly switching between
see it really depended on the scene I
think a lot of it had to do with like
who was because we're both in the film
as well so it's like who
trusting the you know trusting the other
director on like
you know like on if you had to focus
more on your performance and stuff like
that someone's screaming because they
was gonna say hey people are excited I
hate my answers
um I was gonna start streaming so I'm
glad they did
um yeah I think I think the two-headed
Beast sounds pretty cool
um uh and that's sort of things
yeah
the two-headed they're sort of like the
Daniels or like Beast
um but I think that just because we had
all we just have such similar taste and
we knew we both knew what we wanted the
movie to be and there was a shocking few
amount of times you really disagreed
about something and if we did it
whatever literally to I can like think
of only two on off the top of my head
that's it yeah and so
and then a couple of like editing things
but it was um it was so great and I
trusted Finn so much that uh we both
kind of knew whatever the other person
needed to be doing we could sort of
support them and and um and vice versa I
noticed in the credits you thanked Ryan
Gosling
yes
and why just in general because of the
movie drive because Drive is incredible
Drive is incredible Drive I saw a drive
when I was 11 years old my dad took me
to see it and he I was wearing a hat and
he put the Hat over my face the entire
time and I went home and I uh bought the
Drive jacket online with like all my
birthday money and I thought they would
be so cool if I wore it to school and it
didn't fit me at all I was Tiny I was
the tiniest kid in my school and I just
thought if I like was quiet and cool and
and didn't talk then the girls would
like me and it didn't work
um and then I that that you know left
such an imprint on me and then in the
first draft of the script there was so
many Ryan Gosling jokes so there's one
there's one left in the movie but there
was like 30. it was such a big part of
my character
um just this idea that he's obsessed
with like his his male role model is
Ryan Gosling in movies and yeah yeah not
in real life like just the care just the
characters he uh just there's so many
people I think it became a huge thing
online too and had the like literally me
thing which also I I think our movie our
joke's like kind of predated that so I
don't I don't want to say that we were
doing like a meme thing but um we're
doing in 2019. but yeah yeah there's a
oh there's a huge generation of of young
men and uh specifically who were sort of
raised by thinking they were like the
driver or Luke glanton or Holland March
or any of these characters Abby's like
what is what did I get myself into well
thank you for asking about Ryan Gosling
yeah
um I have to wrap with you guys but I
just last question for you too because
otherwise they will kill me uh
when you think about the shoot and you
think about the making of the film like
what's the one day that like really
sticks with you the thing that you're
always going to take away from the
experience that's a really great bit
yeah I think I think I have my well
you're talking on set yeah
was the walk and talk
about this yeah which happened magically
we weren't supposed to walk and then we
ended up and talking it was supposed to
be easy it was like we were gonna shoot
it differently and then there was sort
of it was raining and then the sun was
coming up and we just were like let's
just go do it and then we weren't I
don't think we were even supposed to
shoot it that day which is also one of
the things there were so many great
scenes every day that it was like there
was never a there were never like this
buffered every day was pretty chock-full
of like
all of your favorite scenes and that was
one where it was always it's the first
scene with the two of us together in it
and
um but I think it was supposed to
initially be maybe four or five days
later and all this weather stuff
happened and changed the schedule on
this way and back and then suddenly it
was like I think like 15 minutes and
we're like I think this is what we
should shoot right now they're saying
and then we just started to do it yeah
and it was I guess yeah you're allowed a
certain level of magic I think if you're
lucky a couple times and that felt like
I felt like it was really it was really
really really fun to shoot I would say
that was like one of the I mean
obviously we were like directing a bunch
before but I remember that I remember
really relaxing as a director after that
like and Billy too like both of us just
being so
it's like just being like oh thank God
like just like being like that was like
and both of us like being able to like
step outside as the audience member too
and to be you know because we can be
total cynics and like you should be to a
degree as the Director but this is the
first time I feel like on set we were
both like
oh these are two of me like like it was
like good yeah yeah we're good
um no but it was it just felt great it
felt really great to do that yeah I
could ask you a million other things but
we will continue this conversation after
I've seen the film when it's getting
released
um uh thank you guys so much for coming
in and really congrats on being part of
Toronto seriously it's incredible we're
so happy to be here it's the best